ich habe mir ein Auto gekauft ein alter
Volkswagen Golf Variant Baujahr 2008
nächster Klassiker mein Ziel ist es
jetzt das Baby hier auf Vordermann zu
bringen das zugegebenermaßen seine
besten Tage schon hinter sich hat ich
will aber versuchen das zu ändern und
dafür zu sorgen dass es sogar ein Wert
steigt und mir hinterher jemand mehr
dafür bietet als ich dafür bezahlt habe
ja Haken ich habe kein Plan von Autos
und habe auch noch nie irgendwas an dem
Auto geschaut und nicht mal einen Reifen
habe ich schon mal gewechselt das
höchste der Gefühle war echt einfach mal
Scheibenwischwasser auffüllen diese
geballte Unfähigkeit wollen sie auch die
profi-mechatroniker vom Volkswagen
economy Service nicht entgehen lassen
und werden daher später auf dieses Video
reagieren und mir und auch Euch zeigen
wie es vielleicht ein bisschen richtiger
gegangen wäre es wird ihn halt
wahrscheinlich der ein oder andere
Gruppe Schnitzel auffallen der mir am
Auto passieren könnte ey ihr habt keine
Ahnung was jetzt machen soll um das noch
irgendwie zu retten wir finden jetzt
aber erstmal raus wie ich das heiße
Gefährt ergattert habe wie viel ich
dafür hinblättern musste und ob ich
damit vielleicht mies über den Tisch
gezogen wurde und Reisen dafür zwei
Wochen zurück in die Vergangenheit ich
brauche ein Auto beliebt und auch
bekannt genug damit wir leicht
Ersatzteile bekommen gut genug damit wir
damit auch eine Menge werden aber heraus
sich genug damit wir da auch noch was
zum Verbessern haben und auch eine gute
werksteigerung drin ist ich denke da an
den Golf 5 Marke Volkswagen Modell Gold
Preis bis 5000 € 156 Angebote Getriebe
genau automatisch gibt's nur noch 16
Angebote in der Umgebung hui ehrlich
gesagt und ich weiß es wird immer besser
habe ich noch nie ein gebrauchtes Auto
ausgesucht ein erstes Auto war zwar auch
12 Jahre alt aber was haben wir für mich
von meinem Geld gekauft so rum keine
Ahnung oder sehe ich schon mal was jetzt
gut was hinten das könnten wir
vielleicht reparieren 150 PS ist krass
oder auch gute Kratzer hier unten auch
richtig fette Schrammen das Auto
befindet sich in einer guten Zustand
neue TÜV für weitere Fragen schreiben
Sie
hallo okay ich habe gerufen ja
sieht schick aus
stimmt
da sehe ich mich mit dem Vorschlaghammer
da hätte ich richtig Bock drauf das
auszubrüllen das wäre cool wir rufen an
riesen delle finde ich cool ich habe bei
Ihnen auf mobile den Auto gesehen ah
schon okay alles klar mal schade okay
gut der nächste oha er TÜV des Todes oha
Herren Kombi ist das überhaupt ein
Golfen
Volkswagen fünf Variant kein
reimportfahrzeug boardmappe Scheckheft
zwei Vorbesitzer nur hier Automatik
Klimaautomatik Sitzheizung Tempomat
ballcomputer Alufelgen Facelift
Modellpflege puh ja man könnte man da
mal vorbeikommen und den probefahren
okay 16:30 Uhr alles klar super Ciao
also der wollte jetzt unbedingt dass er
das ohne Gewährleistung verkauft also
wenn er so betont dass es ohne
gewährleisten verkaufen will ey aber er
TÜV bis 2024
[Musik]
wir sind gerade in München und noch
anderthalb Stunden haben wir vor uns
das Auto mal schauen sieht gut aus hat
super viele Schäden aber ich habe auch
keine Ahnung
also das Teil hier ist richtig übel aber
das kommt dann vielleicht sogar beheben
wichtig wäre es nur dass wir den Preis
eingedrückt bekommen das weiß ich jetzt
nicht ob ich es schaffen sie dann hier
diese selbst lackierten stellen
vielleicht können wir noch mal selber
überlackieren und besser im Worst Case
wird immer noch schlechter ähm ja ich
habe mich mal reingesetzt es riecht nach
dem Auto neben meinem Hund gehalten
wurde Zigaretten jetzt nicht schon mal
gut und ich würde sagen dann drehen wir
gleich mal eine Runde es ist Automatik
okay perfekt dann stelle ich mir jetzt
gleich nicht komplett peinlich an
klimaanlage geht auch riecht ein
bisschen aber geht richtig gut also die
ist jetzt schon saukalt gegen super
schnell hey ich finde es krass also von
hier drin funktioniert alles tipptopp
perfekt schreibt mal gerne in die
Kommentare was ihr denkt wie viel das
Auto eigentlich wert ist wir gehen jetzt
noch mal irgendwie auf der Landstraße
weil so bis 30 km/h fährt er schon sehr
sehr gut aber viele Schäden da kann man
auch erst wenn man 100 fährt so
Landstraße Sportmodus hä das Fenster
schließt nicht
macht nicht
mal an vielleicht ist es auch so ein
Schaden den man komplett easy reparieren
kann aber der bei uns jetzt hier gut den
Preis drückt mal schauen
hat er keinen Bock drauf gut dann fangen
wir mal den Händler und schauen wir mal
mit dem Preis ein bisschen drücken
können es wird auch so nehmen aber
müssen wir schauen ob er noch einen
Preis was machen können
so direkt abkaufen treffen wir uns in
der Mitte und fertig vier drei Schmerzen
okay
[Musik]
Papiere Schlüssel fahren wir nach Hause
und jetzt wird dann irgendwie noch was
angemeldet das ist natürlich in
Deutschland super Komplex dann können
wir es abholen dann fahren wir noch mal
die zwei Stunden ich habe einfach ein
Auto gekauft also ich finde es cool dass
ich noch mal 300 € runtergekriegt habe
allerdings sind natürlich auch das
Fensterteil da hinten wirklich kaputt
bei dem Auto hoffe das kostet weniger
ist 200 € zu reparieren sonst war das
richtig schlechter Deal aber das wird
schon
ich hoffe ich glaube das wird schon
während ich auf den ganzen Papierkram
warte habe ich die Zeit schon mal
genutzt um im Internet alles zu
bestellen was wir brauchen unter anderem
zum Beispiel Original-Lack der logisch
eins zu eins dieselbe Farbe hat wie der
im Auto eine Woche hin und her mit der
Versicherung dem Kennzeichen Shop der
Zulassungsstelle und querulantischen
Bargeldautomaten später und der gute
volkswagen golf 5 Variant ist hier ja
ziemlich peiniges passiert
ja das ist schon mal überhaupt nicht gut
da geht nichts mehr und zwar habe ich
gestern vergessene Licht auszumachen ja
das Problem ist jetzt halt dass die
Batterie da drin gar nicht so happy
darüber ist deswegen machen wir da mal
auf ne warte mal vorne ich weiß nicht
mehr wo die ist Google meist unter der
Motorhaube gut perfekt machen wir schon
mal richtig
[Musik]
jetzt wo ich darüber nachdenke wäre es
echt ultra schlau gewesen da schon mal
reinzuschauen bevor ich das Auto kaufen
das da hinten mit der Isolierung sieht
echt nicht so geil aus aber wir können
uns jetzt erstmal die Batterie damit das
Ding da läuft also man kann jetzt
hoffentlich wieder aufladen ich messe
das alles mal wie hart die entladen
wurde fünf Volt 12 Volt haben das weiß
ich 5 Volt ist schon eine ordentliche
Tiefenentladung Tiefenentladung ist
nicht gut die Spannung sollte
bestenfalls zwischen 12,4 und 12,7 Volt
betragen liegt sie unter 12 Volt kann
ein Batterie Defekt vorliegen okay wir
machen es kurz die ist kaputt mega dumm
extrem dumm das heißt die Batterie muss
raus Golf V Autobatterien entfernen
Klemmen im ersten Minuspol bedienen und
dann nach dem Pluspol beim anklemmen
dann genau anders
das klingt ja schon mal Nachbar
dann soll das hier runtergehebelt werden
[Musik]
und hier haben wir die neue hier plus
hier Minus
bombenfest so die Kontakte gehen jetzt
hier nicht 100% drauf darum helf mir ein
bisschen nach nicht zu fest ich weiß es
nicht wie schlau sind die Batterie mit
dem Hammer zu hauen
das ist schon mal fest und jetzt
probierst du aber noch mal
jawohl das heißt ich habe schon mal eine
Sache repariert okay ich habe doch
selber kaputt gemacht aber ich habe
seferiert das ist nice also die
Motorhaube ist so alter dann müssen wir
noch so viel machen dass die wieder
halbwegs drauf aussieht okay wir sehen
das hier die Motorhaube vorne echt
abenteuerlich mal irgendwie lackiert
wurde von irgendeinem line der ja
hoffentlich weniger Ahnung hat als ich
hoffentlich kriege ich nämlich jetzt
besser hin und dafür müssen sie jetzt
einmal abschleifen so dafür mache ich
hier erstmal Stückchen Pappe drauf damit
ich hier nicht später auf das Logo drauf
schleif wir sind voll das jetzt ist so
wie ich gemacht habe weiß ich nicht 80er
Schleifpapier schöne Atemschutzmaske und
es wird jetzt echt will weil ich jetzt
Mode lichten Auto erstmal kaputt machen
[Musik]
also man sieht auf jeden Fall das schon
ordentlich was gemacht wird und hier
wurde auch richtig krass drüber
gespachtelt es tut er mir sogar schon
fast weh jetzt noch mal mit dem
Schleifpapier eine Stufe feiner drüber
[Musik]
so jetzt wird man gereinigt also das
blase ich mal ein bisschen diesen Staub
weg
so jetzt will ich noch mal entfetten
so damit ich jetzt nicht irgendwie alles
voll macht würde ich sagen ein bisschen
abdecken ich mache das auch noch mal
hier so eine Folie rein das klingt jetzt
zumindest in meinem Kopf nach einer
guten Idee so z.B jetzt wir grundiert
das ist so eine Schicht habe ich auch
erst erfahren bei der Recherche hier
fürs Video die man auch vom Lack drauf
macht beim Grundieren ist mir
aufgefallen dass bevor ich abgeschliffen
habe hier ja auch bereits diese Streifen
drauf waren und ein bisschen erinnern
mich die an die Schlieren die bei mir
hier entstanden sind ich könnte mir also
vorstellen dass der Vorbesitzer das
gleiche Problem hatte wie ich na ja
abwarten in 24 Stunden ist die
Grundierung trocken 24 Stunden später
ich habe den Wagen jetzt mal angefangen
weil es draußen aber geregnet hat es ist
ja alles komplett nass ist aber kein
Problem es war lang genug trocken ich
bin jetzt echt am Überlegen ne weil
normal geht das weiter mit dem Lackieren
aber ich würde trotzdem noch mal drüber
polieren weil ich weiß jetzt nicht was
hier davon noch einen Schaden ist und
was eigentlich eine Verschmutzung ist
mal so ein duschabzieher
okay das funktioniert überhaupt nicht
also nehme ich ganz klassischen Schwamm
so ich bin jetzt anders als voll gut
perfekt vorbereitet ist jetzt zum
lackieren ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nicht so aber gut irgendwann muss man
loslegen was ist Lack und Klarlack
erstmal Badetag natürlich
[Musik]
ich glaube man sollte noch nach oben den
abgeben so und zwar habe ich dafür ein
Stück Pappe
von unten an
[Musik]
ja also ich bin mir jetzt nur so zu 10 %
sicher dass das richtige Farbton ist in
die recherchiert habe nach einigen
Durchgängen hat sich die Farbe vom
anfänglichen hellblau immer mehr zu dem
original Farbton des Autos angenähert
und jetzt nach der zweiten Lackschicht
stimmt der Farbton genau meine
Lackierung ist nicht perfekt dafür hätte
man auch die komplette Motorhaube
lackieren müssen aber nachdem der Lack
mehrere Stunden getrocknet hat kommt nun
der Klarlack drauf und damit sieht die
Motorhaube dann hoffentlich ein Stück
schöner aus als vor meinem Eingriff es
ist etwas passiert kann und zwar ist
überall hier so ein grauer Film drauf
ich glaube das ist einfach irgendwie der
Lack ist aus der Luft dass ich jetzt
irgendwie abgesetzt hat komplett komisch
er geht auf jeden Fall leicht ab aber
nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich wäre es
jetzt schlauer wenn ich das noch mal
einfach abwischen würde bevor ich jetzt
quasi weiter noch mal drüber lackiert
mit entfette darüber zu gehen weil das
dümmste überhaupt weil jetzt glaube ich
habe ich den Lack überall drüber
beschmiert und gelöst und
ja
ihr habt keine Ahnung was jetzt machen
soll um das noch irgendwie zu retten ich
Polier jetzt einfach mal drüber
keine Ahnung also viel schlimmer kann es
nicht werden
[Musik]
so zwei Tage später der Klarlack ist
hart finde ich gut sieht auch schon
optisch echt cool aus nur hier oben hat
man diesen ganzen Staub noch und ich
hoffe den kann ich jetzt auch
wegpolieren dafür mache ich jetzt wieder
ein bisschen Polierpaste drauf und jetzt
bevor ich das jetzt überall mache was
ich das noch mal kurz ab weil dann sehe
ich ob das überhaupt
also entweder kommen jetzt davon dass
hier zu wenig poliert hat oder dass ich
jetzt zu viel poliert habe vielleicht
hat er schlau gewesen erstmal diesen
Klarlack Nebel hier abzuwischen
[Musik]
also ich habe wirklich hart gezweifelt
und ich sehe gerade glaube ich auch aus
wie so ein
Lackierer halt aber ich glaube jetzt
wenn ich die ganze restliche Politur
noch abmache ich dachte man sieht er
immer noch eben Übergang es haben die
auch alle im Internet gesagt dass man
das eigentlich nicht macht weil dann
halt über der Übergang da sein wird aber
das ist einfach nichts hey das ist so
krass
[Musik]
weitergehen tut's hier hinten ihr habt
euch vorhin schon den ganzen Kratzer an
der Stoßstange gesehen ich hoffe dass
man die noch ausprobieren kann dafür
muss ich aber als allererstes den Wagen
noch mal umdrehen ja perfekt so
jetzt sind wir einmal das ist schon wild
also ich bin echt gespannt ob man
überhaupt irgendwas noch machen kann
also alles ist manchmal sauber
so es ist grobe Poliermittel
also ich kann mir echt nicht vorstellen
dass dadurch einfach die Katze weggehen
ich glaube da muss ich noch mal drüber
mit dem groben
so jetzt kommt Stufe 2 einmal dreimal
viermal
[Musik]
sieht finde ich so weil ich das
beurteilen kann definitiv besser aus der
vorher nachher Vergleich den ihr gerade
seht wird auf jeden Fall noch mal
deutlich besser zeigen können aber ich
glaube schon dass die ganzen Kratzer
hier ein bisschen weniger auffallen klar
die ganz großen die sind nicht alle
rausgekommen aber ich wollte mich jetzt
gerade den Schaden hier am Fenster
kümmern dass der nicht mehr hoch und
runter geht aber
[Musik]
jetzt geht's einfach ich weiß nicht ob
ich die spontane Selbstheilung jetzt
beruhigen sollte aber ich beschwer mich
auch nicht weniger Arbeit perfekt das
kann man direkt abhaken jetzt geht seine
Innenreinigung und normal macht man
sicherlich so dass man diese Fußmatte
rausnimmt so und ich kann natürlich
draußen abklopfen absaugen alles alles
gut aber das hier unten ja da ist auch
überall Staub drin normal saugt man den
einfach ab und gut ist aber alles geht
da halt eigentlich nie so richtig raus
jetzt habe ich aber auf Instagram so ein
Video gesehen wobei man jemanden
Exzenterschleifer drauf legt den anmacht
und einfach außen nirgendwo kommen dann
einfach tonnenweise Staub die dann
einfach wegschaut das klingt so dumm das
ist jetzt ausprobiert hat hier unten
sogar Klettverschluss also das hält auf
jeden Fall schon mal halbwegs gut
okay krass es funktioniert einfach
genauso wie in dem Video das ist ja geil
ja nicht schlecht
apropos nicht rauskriegen also
AUA ja gut nichtsdestotrotz hat gut
funktioniert
[Musik]
nachdem das Auto dann ordentlich von
innen und von außen geputzt wurde ist
das das Ergebnis und der vorher nachher
Vergleich zeigt was ich aus dem
gebrauchten Volkswagen alles rausgeholt
habe
[Musik]
ihr habt ganz vergessen wie schlimm die
Motorhaube am Anfang doch aussah und bin
schon ein bisschen stolz wie viel besser
ich die Lackierung hinbekommen habe als
der Vorbesitzer auch die Verbesserung
bei den vielen kleinen Kratzern im Auto
durch die Politur kann sich sehen lassen
nochmal zu Erinnerung gezahlt habe ich
4300 Euro für das Auto 5,69 € für die
Grundierung zusätzlich 86,60 € für den
Volkswagen Basislack und Klarlack 24,95
für die Politur und ca 50 Euro
Spritkosten für den Transport des Autos
also insgesamt 4.467 Euro das Ziel muss
es also jetzt sein mindestens das wieder
reinzuholen am besten natürlich viel
mehr und mit der neuen Batterie die ich
zwangsweise einbauen musste werde es
auch wieder wie eine 1 und zwar zum
Autohändler wo ich ihn verkaufen will so
wir sind jetzt hier bei dem Autohändler
in dem ich mein Auto andrehen will hi
grüß Dich Thomas Wolfgang jawohl also
das der Wagen und die würde ich gern
verkaufen schauen wir uns mal die Zeit
zusammen
Kleinigkeiten
genauso hergerichtet und wollen jetzt
verkaufen irgendwelche Mengen bekannt
ist also der hat halt mal vorne glaube
ich ne glaube ich ein Auffahrunfall
gehabt auch etwas mitbekommen ja
Kilometerstand 166 was verlangen sie für
das Fahrzeug haben Sie eine Vorstellung
ich hätte dafür gern 58
der Markt wird ungefähr von diesem
Fahrzeug bei
455 ich denke aber fünf können Sie dafür
verlangen nehmen was willst du jetzt
persönlich ich bin jetzt mein Maximum
liegt bei 27 oh krass okay heftig er
verstehe ich verstehe ich aber krass ich
müsste die Motorhaube nach der King
lassen ich musste hier da noch etwas
machen ich müsste noch Geld investieren
ja zwei sieben kann ich nicht hergeben
das bringt nicht was jetzt aber trotzdem
danke schön kein Problem
jawohl 5000 Euro Markt werden meinte
Händler also über 500 € Preissteigerung
ich finde das krass auch wenn es echt
mehrere Tage Arbeit war macht allein die
Motorhaube das Auto schon ungefähr
zehnmal cooler also wie die davor aussah
würde ich mich echt schon fast schämen
damit rumzufahren für 2,7000 direkt an
den Händler zu verkaufen das kann ich
aber nicht machen da werde ich ihn
lieber selber ich habe auch schon eine
Idee was wir in Zukunft noch mit dem
Auto anstellen werden abonniert mich auf
jeden Fall macht dann verpasst ihr das
nicht ich bin jetzt gespannt was die
Profi Mechatroniker von Volkswagen
economy Service dazu sagen was ich hier
fabriziert habe ein die reparieren
täglich Autos werden bald auf dieses
Video reagieren und kritisieren oder
loben dann was ich angestellt habe und
mit Sicherheit haben die einige Tipps
als wie ihr das in Zukunft besser
umsetzen könnt als ich aber ich bin mehr
als zufrieden und damit bin ich auch
raus macht